what we're going to do in this video is
dig a little bit deeper into confidence
intervals and other videos we compute
them we even interpret them but here
we're going to make sure that we are
making the right assumptions so that we
can have confidence in our confidence
intervals or that we are even calculate
them in the right way or in the right
context so just as a bit of review a lot
of what we do in confidence intervals is
we are trying to assume we're trying to
estimate some population parameter let's
say it's the proportion maybe it's the
proportion that will vote for candidate
we can't survey everyone so we take a
sample and from that sample maybe we
calculate a sample proportion and then
using this sample proportion we
calculate a confidence interval on
either side of that sample proportion
and what we know is that if we do this
many many many times every time we do it
we are very likely to have a different
sample proportion so that B sample
proportion one sample proportion too and
every time we do it we might get this is
maybe this is sample portion two not
only will we get a different I guess you
say center of our interval but the
margin of error might change because
it's we are using the sample proportion
to calculate it but the first assumption
that has to be true and even or make any
claims about this confidence interval
with confidence is that your sample is
random so that you have a random sample
if you're trying to estimate the
proportion of people that are going to
vote for a certain candidate but you are
only serving people at a senior
community well that would not be a truly
random sample or for your only survey
people on a college campus so like with
all things with statistics you really
want to make sure that you're dealing
with a random sample and take great care
to do that the second thing that we have
to assume and this is sometimes known as
the normal condition normal condition
remember the whole basis behind
confidence intervals as we assume that
the distribution of the sample
proportions the sampling distribution of
the sample proportions has roughly a
normal shape like that but in order to
make that assumption that it's roughly
normal we have this
normal condition and the rule of thumb
here is that you would expect per sample
more than ten successes successes and
successes and failures each each so for
example if your sample size was only 10
let's say the true proportion was 50 50
percent or 0.5 then you wouldn't meet
that normal condition because you would
expect 5 successes and 5 failures for
each sample now because usually when
we're doing confidence intervals we
don't even know the true population
parameter what we would actually just do
is look at our sample and just count how
many successes and how many failures we
have and if we have less than 10 on on
either one of those then we are going to
have a problem so you want to expect you
want to have at least greater than or
equal to 10 successes or failures on
each and you actually don't even have to
say expect because you're going to get a
sample and you could just count how many
successes and failures you have if you
don't see that then the normal condition
is not met and the statements you make
about your confidence interval aren't
necessarily going to be as valid the
last thing we want to really make sure
is known as the independence condition
independence condition and this is the
10% rule if we are sampling without
replacement and sometimes it's hard to
do a replacement if you're surveying
people who are exiting a store for
example you can't ask them to go back
into the store or it might be very
awkward to ask them to go back in the
store and so the independence condition
is that your sample size so sample let
me just say n n is less than 10% of the
population size and so let's say your
population were a hundred thousand
people and if you surveyed a thousand
people well that was one percent of the
population so you'd feel pretty good
that the independence condition is met
and once again this is valuable when you
are sampling without replacement now to
appreciate how our confidence intervals
don't do what we think they're going to
do when any of these things are broken
and I'll focus on these latter two the
random sample condition that's super
important frankly
all of statistics so let's first look at
a situation where our independence
condition breaks down so right over here
you can see that we are using our little
gumball simulation and in that gumball
simulation we have a true population
proportion but someone doing these
samples might not know that we're trying
to construct confidence interval with a
95% confidence level and what we've set
up here is we aren't replacing so every
member of our sample we're not looking
at it then putting it back in we're just
gonna take a sample of 200 and I've set
up the population so that it's a far
larger than 10% of the population and
then when I drew a bunch of samples so
this is a situation where I did almost
1,500 samples here of size 200 what you
can see here is the situations where our
true population parameter was contained
in the confidence interval that we
calculated for that sample and then you
see in red the ones where it's not and
as you can see we are only having a hit
so to speak the overlap between the
confidence interval that we're
calculating in the true population
parameter is happening about 93 percent
of the time and this is a pretty large
number of samples that's truly at a 95%
confidence level this should be
happening 95% of the time similarly we
can look at a situation where our normal
condition breaks down and our normal
condition we can see here that our
sample size right here is 15 and
actually if I scroll down a little bit
you can see that the simulation even
worsse me there are fewer than 10
expected successes and you can see that
when I do once again I did a bunch of
samples here I did over 2,000 samples
even though I'm trying to set up these
confidence intervals that have that
every time I computed that I have over
time that there's a kind of a 95 percent
hit rate so to speak here there's only a
94 percent hit rate and I've done a lot
of samples here and so the big takeaway
not being random will really skew things
but if you don't feel good about how
normal the actual sampling distribution
of the sample portions are or if your
sample size is a fairly large chunk of
your population and you're not replacing
and you're violating the independence
condition then your confidence level
that you think your computing for when
you make your confidence
intervals might not be valid